esta casa perteneció a la misión de
francia que eran los curas obreros
y ha albergado del 73 al 87 un flyer de
acogida para los resistentes
latinoamericanos en esta casona cerca de
parís vivió la isla cuando con 12 años
llegó a francia en 1982 huyendo como
otros 15 mil chilenos de la dictadura de
pinochet
cuando comenzó el estallido si una de
las asambleas de chilenos en francia que
se hizo eco de las reivindicaciones en
chile los exiliados siempre hemos
seguido luchando estas elecciones el
gobierno negoció igual que el pacto que
hicieron con pinocho de la gente que se
presenta como independiente sin partido
prácticamente no tiene ninguna chance de
ganar entonces tiene como
obligatoriamente que inscribirte a un
partido y la gente que salió a la calle
salió a decir justamente que no quieren
más partido atención otomana ton que es
agua también le trabaja en un colegio
parisino vino francia estuvieron
doctorado en filosofía hace cinco años
antes de la pandemia participaba
activamente también en la asamblea de
chilenos en parís
el estadio social me encontraba con
francia y tampoco pude restarme de
manifestar mi compromiso y mi intención
con que chile cambie realmente a nivel
la estructura que miles se contenta con
seguir la actualidad de chile a la
distancia no puede hacer nada más ya que
los chilenos en el extranjero no sólo
podrán votar este domingo al no
constituir un distrito electoral con
representantes elegidos estamos
profundamente ligados a chile nuestra
familia nuestros amigos e incluso mis ex
estudiantes viven en chile y me gustaría
que ellos pudiesen vivir de verdad en un
estado democrático que permitiera
condiciones sociales básicas de
existencia también hay que entender que
los procesos de elección no son las
únicas formas en las que se puedan
manifestar la participación al
compromiso político su compromiso de ser
profesora aquí se familiariza con un
sistema de educación pública de calidad
una de las demandas del estallido que
espera ver algún día realizada en chile